welcome to thick boy fight news let's
Dive In
Patty pimlic gave Insight on where he
stands Weight Wise heading into fight
week responding to a fan on Twitter
Patty revealed that he currently weighs
169 pounds just 13 pounds shy of the 156
pound limit he will need to reach by
Saturday Paddy's out of Camp weight has
been the subject of much scrutiny
weighing in as high as 200 pounds
following his submission victory over
Rodrigo Vargas however a recent photo
tweeted by his coach Paul Reed appears
to corroborate Paddy's weight loss
claims Paddy responded to the Tweet with
his trademark confidence by saying we
ready to kill at Vortex Paul R got us in
Prime condition 4 Kos for team at
next-gen MMA pool next weekend Paddy
recently spoke with the overlap about
fighter pay he argued that fighters who
complain about fighter pay need to
realize that they need to be just as
entertaining outside of the Octagon as
they are inside people moan about the
wages
Autumn fighter I've got no Personality
yeah I mean it's it's always stuff like
that I mean they never let go oh yeah
it's my own faults because
yeah or I'm a boredom bastard you know
what I mean some people can't talk on a
mic put the boss in the cage it's
interesting that because you do it does
tend to be the ones who've obviously got
the skill but also the personality I
always say you've got to have the whole
package Patty's teammate Molly McCann
added that she feels happy with what the
UFC provides Fighters
no other promotion would fly you around
the world to put you up in five-star
hotels when you arrive you send them
your weight and they'll come up with a
refeed program they'll give you food all
week they're with you non-stop then
you've got the performance Institute
which is like the Eis we've got one in
Las Vegas where you're allowed to go and
use for free so you've got constant free
physio strength and conditioning
programs
former UFC champion Frankie Edgar is
making plans for his retirement in a
recent interview with ESPN Edgar shared
that he is seeking one last fight at
bantamweight before hanging up the
gloves Edgar gave further Insight on the
decision to retire by saying I've been
kicking the idea of retirement around
since my last fight the last two fights
obviously didn't go the way I wanted
them to if I'm being honest I would
fight forever but that's kind of selfish
to my family and the people that care
about me I need to announce my
retirement so I can have a retirement
fight and sail off into the sunset Edgar
went on to reveal that he is eyeing the
Madison Square Garden card that is
reported to be taking place in November
of this year and he even has an opponent
in mind I'm never one to call out or
pick anybody but I'll say a name just
because I think it's more of a legacy
fight I know he has a fight coming up
and who knows how that could go down but
Dominic Cruz he was a champion at 135
when I was a champion at 155. we were
both pretty much the top of the division
that could be a fun fight
not to be left out Bryce Mitchell threw
his name into the Muddy Waters at the
top of the featherweight division
following the events of UFC Long Island
thug nasty laid out his path to the
title on Twitter by saying can I fight
yair and get a title shot after I win
because if so I will do that
Bryce might be left waiting a
featherweight Champion Alexander
volkanowski's reported hand surgery
comes to fruition when asked if a yair
Rodriguez versus Josh Emmett interim
title fight Could Happen Dana White
responded
volkanowski I think is going to have
surgery on his hand I think there's
something wrong with his hand you're
asking if Rodriguez versus Emmett for an
interim title is a possibility I like it
I don't hate it
Jake Paul posted an Instagram video from
a hospital bed revealing that he has
suffered a back injury but will still be
able to take part in his scheduled bout
with haseem Rahman Jr at Madison Square
Garden on August 6th
all right Jake I'm filming so guys I'm
in the hospital I had an accident
still going to be able to fight August
6th so get your tickets at msg.com
before they sell out but I broke my back
hurrying the promotion for this event
it's broken
oh my God I broke my back carrying the
last five fights promotion my opponents
never sells you [ __ ]
do something
these [ __ ] never sell [ __ ] they
couldn't sell a pen to a writer while
the video is clearly a joke to help
promote the fight this isn't the first
time Paul has complained about his
opponent's ability to sell fights
ESPN's marked rimondi reported on Monday
that Nate Diaz's UFC contract has an
expiration date for fall 2022.
the word of words between Dana White and
Diaz continued over the weekend during
the UFC Long Island post-fight
conference
Dana didn't even entertain the idea when
asked about a recent Nate Diaz interview
where he trolled Dana by saying only
Francis naganu and Israel addisonia are
on his level
the last one for me then it is a Nate
question I'm curious you were in a
meeting with him and he said an
interview that he said the only
opponents in the UFC he'd like to fight
or or interested it was in ganu and
adesanya do you remember that meeting
and what was your reaction when he said
that
that Nate Diaz said and gone you are not
a sign they said the only guys in the
UFC he'd like be interested in fighting
was angano and arasanya but it's not
that he wanted to fight them just they
were the only best ones in the in the
sport right now and what should I say to
that I'm curious what your reaction was
when you say that you just sort of go
okay
I mean imagine having a conversation
like that I mean it's come on
I hate Diaz versus Francis and ganya
what should I say is that what standard
like
oh
this is crazy
Diaz took to Twitter to respond to the
UFC president saying
Dana said Francis nagani was injured and
couldn't fight right now IDK why he was
so confused in interview and in the last
nine months I've been offered zero
fights and I asked her five legitimate
opponents thank you for the kind words
can I go now per ESPN's Brett okamoto
Hamza shamaya vs Nate Diaz has been
verbally agreed to the five-round fight
will reportedly Main Event UFC 279 on
September 10th at T-Mobile Arena
Hamza commented on the fight to ESPN by
saying
I am going to handle Nate Diaz's funeral
with the UFC akamoto later tweeted that
Nate Diaz's representative Zach
Rosenfeld confirmed the date and
opponent rosenfell added this is a fight
Nate has been asking for since April
looks like the Whiteboard might have
been right after all one Championship
announced a multi-year partnership with
Prime video that will give the streaming
giant exclusive rights to broadcast 12-1
Championship events per year the first
event will be announced later this year
speaking about the deal vice president
of global Sports at Amazon Marie Donohue
said we are proud to add exclusive
coverage of one Championship events to
our suite of Marquee live sports
offerings in addition to offering a full
Suite of martial arts disciplines one
Championship shares our mutual
commitment to elevate female athletes
boasting five reigning female world
champions looking for more original MMA
content check out the rest of thick boy
YouTube exclusive elusive interviews
opinion and fight analysis is available
weekly on the shop show food truck
Diaries and Fight Night flashbacks
subscribe so you don't miss any of the
action